- All right Red, Red where are you from
where did you grow up?
- Um, I was a foster kid
so I was originally
born in Arizona
and like at a day old my
mom took me back to Missouri
where I stayed until
about six years of age
and then I kind of bounced
around from state to state so,
I don't really have a good upbringing
to say I had a childhood anywhere
cause I was kind of
scattered all over the place.
- Different families?
- Yeah, I mean um,
I stayed with my mom a lot uh,
she kind of kept me as a profitable like
cause you know?
She did bad things so eventually I like
couldn't take it anymore
and child protective services came
and took me away so after that I got,
you know stuck in the
system unfortunately.
- What kind of a kid
were you as a teenager?
- Hmm,
I don't know.
I hid about my life as much as I could
so I think I lived a lie pretty much
my whole childhood and my teen.
I tried to stay involved in
school as much as possible but
it was hard.
So you know,
I wasn't understood in life,
even though I have a very loud
and (indistinct) like character
in high school it just wasn't like that.
I wasn't popular
but I wasn't a loser either
so people knew who I was.
I kind of was mischievous
I got into a lot of trouble like fights
and staff like that so.
- Did you finish high school?
- Yeah, of course. I
graduated valedictorian
- Oh really?
- Yeah I did.
- Well,
- Yeah
(sighs)
It was a great accomplishment since that
no one on my mom's side
ever graduated high school,
so I was the first female on
her side to actually finish
school and go to college.
- And where did you go after that?
- Um,
I bounced around here and there,
Um,
I actually got sexually assaulted
by my older son's father and
that's how I got pregnant.
I was in college,
and I thought I was in love and I was
totally something different.
Uh,
he was a child predator you know?
So um,
I pretty much you know.
To be honest with you it's a blur,
my whole life.
I kind of try not to think back on it
cause I'm just trying to find
the positive in all of these
chaos.
- Did anything like that
ever happen to you as a kid?
- Yeah, my mom used to sell me for drugs.
She used to do bad things to me
and let people do bad things to me.
But um,
I didn't let that
be the cause of
me being an ugly person cause
I always had a big heart.
I just um,
in fear of other people
but I did a good job of like
masking it and hiding it.
I actually didn't realize
until recently with
everything that I've been
through since I moved to Cali
that am actually a lot weaker
than people think that I am.
Um, am used to being a control freak
so that people can't see
the disarray in my life.
- So you moved to California how long ago?
- Two years ago now,
I moved to get away from my kids' father.
He used to abuse me
very very badly
and
I did,
I started over when he went to prison
after him leaving me and my kids homeless
and everything was going
good and my house burnt down
and I ended up having to get involved in
like
things that I wouldn't normally consider
but with the money I danced
and I did like you know online things
selling my feet pictures
and staff like that you know,
innocent.
You know, um
but everything that I did was
more abuse on my
mental because of the
things that happened to me
when I was younger.
I just felt like I was victimizing myself
all over again in a way but
I would do anything for my children.
So if that means that
I got to get out there
and be in the streets
and do things that most women
shouldn't have to necessarily do,
I'll do them because no one else
is going to take of them
and love and makes sure
that they've got everything
that they need but me.
And since I didn't have that growing up
I vowed that to myself.
When I was finally was able to
have a baby
cause I was told for
years I'd never have one.
So my first son even
though he's a rape baby,
he's the most beautiful thing I ever saw.
He changed my whole life,
he made feel important and valued
and I finally believed
that someone could love me
other than grown men
(giggles)
So,
- You have two kids?
- I have three children actually.
I have two with my husband
um a little boy
and then I have a little girl too.
My son just turned six on
the sixth of this month.
- So the first child was a product of
- Of rape
- Rape.
- Yes sir.
- And that's
your son,
- Yes, my oldest son.
He's eight years old.
- Did you marry the father?
- No I did not marry the father.
Um,
I actually
got with my husband
about two years after
my oldest sone was born.
- Okay, so so the first son
is a product of that rape.
- Yeah
- And then you have a son with your
- My husband
- Your husband, and
- And a daughter
- And a daughter,
- Yes, they're actually
tattooed on my leg.
Tyree, King and Princess.
It's the biggest tattoo that I have
cause am just so proud
to have such three amazingly
rambunctious kids pretty much.
- Where, where are your kids today?
- Um,
they got taken by
the state of California
and ever since then I don't even
recognize who I am anymore.
Cause they've taken the only thing
that kept me grounded
and having some type of feeling of worth.
I mean who can go
almost a whole yea.. all of
their whole life am almost 29
and never felt loved.
And then to feel it and
to know what it's like
and then have it taken from me for
a misunderstanding at best.
But due to the fact that I
had a lot of trauma done to me
as a young girl
and then the fact that my
husband literally beat the shit
out of me all the time.
Um,
they used that against me
and am all the way
in another state
where I don't belong really,
but
I felt like moving to California
and trying to get over
being abused victim
and start claiming me
being a survivor again.
It was supposed to be a
wonderful time here like
and it turned out to be
one of the worst decisions
I made in my life so.
Sorry, thank you.
- So today you are working
(indistinct chatter)?
- Um
no pretty much.
It's um,
I don't like to be out
on the streets like that.
So I do more intimate
settings like um,
some of my clients like
to be like beat and staff like that
so am more into like the
dominatrix type of thing.
Am not really into the sensual
like having a guy touch me.
I prefer to just beat the crap out of him.
I know that sounds kind of bad.
- And you do that through like online?
- Yeah,
like um,
you know dungeons and staff like that
they have quite a bit of them actually.
More than you'd think.
Um,
and I didn't even know about any of that
until I met a girl in one of my classes
through counseling.
She said if you want to get your anger out
in a way and be able to dress pretty
and you know get paid good money like
, you should come where I work at.
At first I thought she was joking,
you know.
I have seen things in
like TVs and magazines
and all that about you
know dom and submissive.
Does it make me feel better?
Sometimes,
do I like doing it?
No, it's very demeaning and I feel like
am worth more than
just that
and
I felt like I was finally going to
get to leave that
until
my life got ripped apart.
So now am back
doing what
is familiar I guess you can say.
Am not proud of it,
and I prefer
never to have anybody know but
if I could just change one person's life.
I mean I guess exposing my soul
to the world in a way.
You know.
It's embarrassing but
people can't understand
the depths of it
unless they've had to live it.
There's a lot of judgemental
in this world that
consider women like me
or you know
the actual street workers
you know with pimps and so on and so forth
to be dirty
and
not very
worth much
but
I feel like we are worth
more than most people period
because we sacrifice things that
the common person would
think is disgusting
and
this is a bad world.
It's a doggy dog's world
and either you eat or
you'll going to get eaten.
There's no in between at
this point in time especially
because of the way society is.
So one thing I do know is that am,
am determined and I know
that this is not my life
and am not going to fall
and let it beat me.
I just been trying to get
a lawyer to save my kids.
That's it.
- So you'll never want
to let go of this til
you get your kids?
- Yeah like
I only started
picking up clients which
I only have like three.
You know what I mean
cause I really don't like doing this.
You know I had a good
job, I had two good jobs
but because I cried
everyday at work whenever
I heard a little kid
in the hall way or
anything that would just trigger me
to start having a panic attack
so I got fired.
My jobs couldn't understand
and I understand that too cause
from a business aspect
that's not their fault or their problem.
But I've had a lot of bad things
happen to me since I've been in LA.
I've gotten sexually
assaulted a few times,
my car stolen a few times
and instead of DCFS seeing
that it's a cry for help
because I have no idea
what the fuck am doing
out here on these streets like that.
Um,
they're condemning me
and saying am a bad mom
and I make bad decisions but
I didn't ask to be hear.
Period.
Other than coming to Cali
yeah but I mean the situation
so.
- You feel like your
back is against the wall?
- No I feel like
the wall is on top of my back,
it's that it's that bad now
because um,
am an extreme person,
I love hard
and I genuinely feel like
if I don't get my children back
things aren't going to
be pretty for anybody
especially not myself because
am not going to feel like
there's a need for me.
People tell me you got to wait
the years until they grow up.
How? Am a mess right now
how am I going to be in twelve years,
sixteen seventeen years?
Am just lucky am not strong out on drugs
and am not that far under.
You know um,
I could be sometimes I really think about
- Are you using at all?
- No,
um
I've used before
before I had kids
and I got clean.
I've considered relapsing
quite a few times
only due to the fact that
that's what am actually being
my kids got taken for.
Another girl had some
paraphernalia on her purse
and because it was my car and my daughter.
And I kind of outsmarted
the police you know
sarcastically like
you not pulling me over am already parked
I haven't even driven anywhere
you know even know who drove the car
and because of that reason he
screwed me and my children and
he gave me a horrible charge
of child endangerment with the
intent to cause great bodily
damage or death on my daughter.
And they put a restraining order on me and
they really beating me down
let's just put it that away
and they've sabotaged me the whole way.
So I've had to do whatever I've had to do
to make it
because I've slept out in the streets
and I've had to eat out of garbage cans.
Um,
I don't judge people,
I've never been a judge of people
and I definitely don't now
because of how low I've had to go.
Straight up,
I don't steal from people
though out on the streets,
I don't do any of those type of things,
I don't get over people and lie
am pretty brutally honest
sometimes am so honest
that I hurt the people
that I kind of care about
and they don't want to
deal with me anymore but
if I have to admit to my
life being as shitty as it is
everyone else around me
has to live in reality too.
There's no such thing as LA LA land.
You know,
except for the ones running
around out here half naked
flipping out because of drugs.
You know,
I keep telling myself that could be you
so be happy with where you are right now
but I haven't had any
happiness in over a year.
- Is this the lowest part
of your life right now?
- Probably.
I thought being with my husband was
and
sleeping in cars until I was
able to obtain a home for me
and my kids until it
burnt down you know so.
But definitely losing my children,
and fighting as hard as I've been fighting
and all of these things
stacking up against me
you know what I mean?
DCFS is winning in a way
but
one thing they don't understand
is that am not a quitter
so they going to have to
pry my dead hands away from my kids
just because they're
all that matter to me.
Without me there's no Red,
there's no me period.
So
as bad as I try to do the right thing
I tend to find myself doing
the wrong thing sometimes
but that that's because that's
what's accepted in the world,
the ugly you know.
So because of that
I've had to go against my
own morals and judgment
just to be able to make sure that
I can have somewhere to sleep
or when I show up to a visit
I have what I need for my kids.
One thing I don't do is
show up empty handed ever.
Like that's out, I don't care.
- How often do you see your kids?
- Um, it started off
quite frequently and then
as I was progressing
the DCFS worker started to do like really
not so on the books
type of things you know.
Lying on me
um,
mixing up paper work.
She framed me for a dirty
drug test for alcohol
and I don't even drink
and so they want me in the drug program
that I shouldn't even have to take
it's like I might as well be on drugs
you know what I mean
but am not
and I've tested so many tests for them.
And I suffer from an illness
like am not healthy
I have Lupus and Epilepsy
so through all of this my health is still
you know in a bad state but
I don't care what it is again
am going to do it for my children you know
but
without some type of advocate
or without someone more important than me
I guess you could say to advocate for me
my kids are going to be another
set of children lost in the system.
I was lost in the system, I was abused
- So your kids are where right now?
- They're here in LA.
My oldest child
didn't want to live my husband's family
mind you he has no one but me
because of the situation
how he was conceived
and my youngest children are
with their great grandmother
in um West LA.
So they're all very close but
if I even attempt to go
to them without permission
or supervision I will
get in a lot of trouble.
But you know and am just
baffled by how corrupt
this whole system is
and how one lie
turned my whole life
from what I thought was really upside down
to completely on it's face
you know.
I go over my Facebook and like
it like shows you memories
and literally there's
posts that I just shared of
for the past few days of how
miserable I was back then
and I literally have nothing
positive to say.
It's fifty million times worse now
cause am screwing up my kid's life
one thing that I vowed I wouldn't do.
So ,
do I hope for the best, of course
but do I feel like it's going nowhere, yes
and do I like am going to lose my life
most definitely
but
it's all
in the hands of whatever
I guess at this point.
(sighs)
Sorry.
- All right
thank you thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah.
I hope you
figure out a way to get back
together with your kids.
Thank you
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much
- Yeah, no worries